with Avengers infinity war fast
approaching fans are getting totally
geeked up at the promise of finally
seeing the heroes of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe face off against the
ultimate evil fan oohs but once the
wrinkly purple Titan is presumably
defeated who will the next big bad guy
be in the MCU well no one really knows
but we do know who it won't be thanks to
complex licensing issues here's a look
at some villains Marvel can't use in
their movies Galactus if there's one
villain who's bigger than Thanos both
literally and figuratively
it's Galactus planet devouring force of
nature born before the Big Bang even
created our universe in the comics he's
pretty much the ultimate unbeatable
power in the world of movies however his
rights belong to Fox the results is one
incredibly boring and disappointing
cameo as an angry cloud in Fantastic
Four rise of the Silver Surfer Galactus
would be amazing in the MCU but for now
he stuck in bad movie limbo with the
rest of the Fantastic Four
we all listened all the you
dr. doom like Galactus dr. Doom's rights
are tied up with the Fantastic Four
unlike lactis though you may actually be
resilient enough to break free of the
Fantastic Four's legacy of crappy movies
though versions of the bad doctor have
already appeared in every Fantastic Four
film through 2017 it was recently
revealed that Fox is developing a
standalone Doctor Doom solo film that
sounds promising but it also means we
won't be seeing doom take on the
Avengers in the MCU anytime soon I would
like to stock Magneto flax is a pretty
spotty track record with their superhero
films but one tomato tulino is the
character of magneto who's been expertly
played by both Ian McKellen and Michael
Fassbender over the past two decades in
the comics magneto has frequently
branched out from the world of mutants
to battle heroes like the Avengers but
as long as the x-men films remain
profitable there's no chance Fox will
let Magneto's rights revert to Marvel
Studios as the character is a
cornerstone of the franchise which is
too bad because it would be cool to see
them try to reconcile the two different
versions of Magneto's children venom
Sony kept venom off the big screen for
years following his underwhelming debut
in Sam Raimi's spider-man 3 but he'll
soon return in a standalone feature
starring Tom Hardy that's reportedly
meant to launch the studio's own version
of the Marvel Universe of course exactly
how this is going to work now that
spider-man himself is appearing in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is still
unclear
so it's possible venom could eventually
crossover between universes which would
be cool considering venom eventually
ended up joining the guardians of the
galaxy in the comics so we'll see other
Spidey villains if the fate of venom is
confusing things are even more unclear
when it comes to the rest of Spidey's
rogues gallery Sony reportedly is
developing a film featuring both black
cat and silver sable so it looks like
they're off the board and once upon a
time Sony had plans to do a sinister six
film featuring a team up between
villains like electro Doctor Octopus and
Mysterio however sinister six-member the
vulture already appeared in the MCU and
the post-credits teaser of spider-man
homecoming into that more members of the
team such as the Scorpion may be joining
him soon but until we hear otherwise
fans should assume that all of Spidey's
villains are off-limits when it comes to
the MC
sabertooth at best 2009's Wolverine
Origins was a missed opportunity
squandering characters like Deadpool and
gambit in service of a truly joyless
movie and worst Fox wasted a great
performance by Liev Schreiber as
Sabretooth who hasn't been seen in the
x-men film since the dream is over the
Beast is awake my name is Victor creepy
the fact that Fox isn't actually using
Sabretooth makes it especially galling
that Marvel can't use them in their
films either because there are plenty of
places where you can fit in wouldn't
Sabretooth versus Black Panther blow
your mind alas as long as Marvel doesn't
own the film right the best we can do is
hope he pops up in another x-men movie
apocalypse
as far as x-men movies go apocalypse is
a relatively recent villain and x-men
apocalypse was a pretty disappointing
showcase for the character considering
what a world-class threat ease in the
comics in one alternate universe
storyline apocalypse actually conquered
the world and reshaped it in his own
image that sounds like the perfect type
of villain to follow in Vanessa's
footsteps given the good guy to the MCU
a real threat to fight against for now
however like all these other great
characters apocalypse is stuck in Fox's
hands thanks to the true enemy of Marvel
superheroes bad business deals thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
you